everybody what is going on welcome to
another video in this video I'm gonna be
giving my review of the oculus rift so
this is my oculus rift it's actually
this and then plus you get this
positional tracker here which tracks
basically where the rift is in space
sorry I couldn't like pull it out really
far it's wired and it goes between or
back behind my computer and stuff and
anyone pull it so anyway pretty cool
that positional tracker in theory is
supposed to like sit on top of your
monitor and be like five feet from you
and facing you and all this but that
thing can be like anywhere like I've had
it like down on my desk not even facing
and like it's still trash really well so
well I don't really know how it works
but it works so anyway the rift what are
the good things what are the bad things
and what are the amazing things
basically the bad things are the lenses
so they come and they have two different
lenses they've got one for regular
people and one for nearsighted people
I'm nearsighted so I tried the
nearsighted lens not powerful enough so
one of things people want to know is you
know are you gonna go blind using the
oculus rift and the answer is no because
your eyes are not focusing so like
whenever you have like say you're
playing a Game Boy and you're holding
the Game Boy up to your face like this
your eyes are having to focus on that
screen like you know a half an inch away
or whatever and with the oculus rift
that's not really the case right you
have the screen here but then you got
these two lenses and what the lenses are
doing is they're adding distance between
you and the screen so so yes you're
looking at a screen that's close but
your eyes aren't aren't actually
focusing on the screen at that close
like this is so you know you're not
gonna go blind using it but there's
actually a lot of research on that so if
you're really curious on it you can you
can look it up I'm not an optometrist so
anyways what are my thoughts on this
thing honestly it's it's a lot better
than I thought like I wasn't really sure
what to expect with it I'd never
actually tried or demoed an oculus rift
so I didn't really know like if it was
gonna be like if it was overhyped or if
it was really good but it's actually
really impressive for one I didn't
expect it to be as like 3d feeling as it
is like like everything is 3d so it's
like looking like watching like if you
ever seen like a 3d movie or something
it's basically like that - the whole red
and blue nonsense and so that's really
cool I'm really impressed with the 3d
the screen itself is is actually really
panoramic there are some times when it
doesn't feel panoramic and sometimes
where it does I'm not really sure what
changes that because the screen is a
fixed size with the rift but some games
do it really well in some games like
don't I don't know and but I would say
the the number one thing with the rift
and it's only a thing with the dk2
is that you have positional tracking so
if I'm sitting here and I have the rift
on my head and I look this way I'm
actually looking that way in the game or
looking this way up or down that's
incredible and that really gives you an
immersive effect into the game so that
is probably the number one thing so
that's why the dk2 just totally blows
the dk1 out of water so before the dk1
was basically a 3d screen on your face
that's basically it
and so I think the dk2 is pretty much
maybe a dumbed down version but I don't
know that they're gonna be able to add
too many more features at that point
they are coming out of the consumer
version apparently within months of now
and I believe the price point this one
was three hundred and fifty dollars but
they want the consumer version to be two
hundred and fifty dollars and I don't
really see why they can't do that so I
think that that will be the case so in
speaking of cases this should have come
with a case it does not come with a case
and it should have anyways
so or at least like it cover like not
even a case just just something to like
cover over here so dust doesn't get it
anyway um where was I okay so so games
and stuff like that so I mean how is it
well first of all motion sickness if the
game is not really made for the rift or
if your computer's not fast enough when
you're looking around
it like judders a little bit so if
you've set everything to higher your
computer is running too hard that's
gonna happen it's just lag basically and
that will make you sick and no different
than to like a lot of games again that
aren't made for the rift when they're at
a loading screen everything is solid so
you could look around and nothing
happens
well after playing the rift and being
able to look around and then now you
like look around and nothing changes
that's really disorienting so that too
needs to stop but anyway what I was I
think most impressed about is the amount
of support the dk2 actually already has
so the dk2 is not a consumer model it's
a development kit period so I kind of
thought that you would just play demos
with it and that was basically all
you've had with in a really short time
though I found out you can play
half-life 2 with the oculus rift which
is like a first-person shooter game and
really probably one of the more famous
games of its time
or at least impressive games of its time
so it's like a little bit pre
PlayStation 2 graphics or something but
you can play that on the oculus rift in
that game I would say is the best game
for the oculus rift ok because it's a
first-person shooter and but it gives
you the true effect of full like
immersive nests into the game none of
the other games have really done that
there's a couple of demos that have
where especially if you're in a cockpit
so if you're like in a fighter jet a
helicopter or a eurotruck alright if
you're in a truck or car like a racing
game stuff like that those are I think
we're the oculus shines the most because
in real life you're actually sitting
down and you can't move whereas with a
first-person shooter in theory you can
spin around 180 degrees and run down the
hallway can't do that while you're
wearing an oculus rift you first of all
you probably run out of cord but also
you play slam into a wall so you can't
do that
boy interestingly enough not only is
half-life 2 available there's a driver
called vorb X now I don't really know
how long these guys will be in the game
just simply because I think game makers
will start incorporating drivers for
oculus rift what with with vortex what
you can do is you can play older games
or even kind of current games so
battlefield 3 for oh the Call of Duty's
Need for Speed games like a huge list
scream all these stuff you can even play
on the oculus rift using the driver I've
only played battlefield 4 with it and
that try to play need for speed but for
some reason a need for speed like my
menu is like switching really really
fast between options and I can't
actually play the game so I'm a little
bummed about that but because I also
have a driving wheel shifter pedals I've
got everything for need for space no I
really want that to work
but anyway so you can do that you can
get the driver and at play a bunch of
games and honestly I was really
impressed with how easy it was to set
everything up ok so I have 4 monitors
here in the rift acts as a fifth monitor
basically you can use direct to rift and
then it works a little different for the
most part director rift does not work
you have to treat rift as its own little
monitor and if you don't have windowed
mode in your games you have to treat the
rift as your main monitor that's a huge
problem
because it's it's got like this this
double vision stuff so like if you're
looking at a regular image on the rift
it's you can't see sheet ok but another
interesting thing though and why I think
the rift is is and really VR is the
future is the following
there is another demo called it's just
called virtual desktop and what it is is
it's just your best upright on the rift
so it's a little 3d but what what the
kicker is you can make your screen as
big as you want or as small as you want
you can make it flat you can make it
curved and do all kinds of stuff so like
for example every single one of my
monitors I got four monitors here so
I've got like a lot of space each
monitor was $200 so this is $1,000 of
monitors right here whereas this you can
buy this for $350 and or the consumer
edition hopefully will be 250
so a quarter of the price have four
monitors or six or eight right you got
unlimited monitor space right same thing
with like television movies that kind of
stuff you watch it on the Rif to have a
gigantic screen not only that but you
can have like immersive videos immersive
movies and stuff like that and there are
already immersed movies out right now
it's crazy and awesome for you more
risque folk I thought you know the
there's there's it's kind of a joke but
it's serious the oculus rift there is
porn on the oculus rift I thought okay
this is just computer graphics kind of
stuff no these the porn makers have gone
above and beyond everyone's expectations
they have the they're just like
recording it with like 360-degree
panoramic stuff right and so it's
totally immersive porn - right and it's
real people it's not computer stuff like
everything and then you've got so you've
got porn industry doing it just because
they can do it short-term and like they
have the funding and people are gonna
buy it
but like also like movies that are
coming out just plain movies non
pornographic movies you're having you're
we're starting to see like first person
first person movies coming out where you
can look around in the actual movie as
it's happening so like I saw one that
was like a first-person movie for I
don't know some like war like movie
anyway uh just really like crazy stuff
like I I'm really interested to see how
all of this plays out like I said it's a
lot further along than I thought like I
thought this was still really kind of
beta stuff and it is beta but if this is
beta
I don't know what the real is gonna be
like but it's it's impressive that's all
I have to say so I highly recommend it
if you have the money to spend go for it
although oculist
did recently come out like just a few
days ago and said their consumer model
is actually months away it's not a long
ways away so you know that could be six
months but it they're saying that it's
actually pretty close so you might want
to hold out for that but just just know
that like I it's definitely a lot
further along than I thought I had no
idea basically everything across the
spectrum is way further along and way
better than I thought it was going to be
so anyway that's my glowing review for
the oculus rift and also I would say the
best game for right now is half-life 2
and the reason is half-life 2 half-life
2 was not made for the rift but I think
someone went through and actually like
made it for the rift basically whereas
like with battlefield when I'm playing
that it's really more like I'm looking
at a big 3d screen right that's not so
immersive where like with half-life 2 if
I look to the left like this I'm looking
just like that to the left or like this
I'm looking perfectly that amount
up-down everything well as with
battlefield 4 when I'm playing that and
I'm looking around it's more likely when
I look over here I'm really just looking
at like the top right of the screen
right because battlefield 4 does not
really support the oculus rift right so
this is just a driver that goes on top
it makes it 3d which is really cool but
it doesn't it doesn't have that
immersive effect like half-life 2 does
so I still think my favorite thing is
half-life 2 I probably won't always play
battlefield with the oculus rift but it
is fun on the oculus rift it's mostly
just fun like fly like jets and
helicopters around with the rift like
not fight anybody because the other
problem too
the other problem too right now with the
oculus rift it's really pixelated so if
you've ever looked at it like a
television screen really close you can
like see all the little pixels you can
do that on the oculus rift that's a
problem especially on battlefield where
the the person you might be aiming at is
a total of maybe like 5 pixels or
something and when you're looking at in
that close it's really hard to like
register that oh that's where the person
is so normally I'm okay at battlefield
but when I put on the oculus rift I'm
horrible it's really fun but you're
gonna die a lot and so that's kind of a
downside needs to be a lot crisper but
like I said I'm Way more impressed and I
thought I would be with this I wasn't
really sure if I'd wind up buyer's
remorse or not but I was really curious
like where are we and
virtual reality and we're really we're
really far so anyways that's that if you
guys have any questions or comments
about the IO script for this video or
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all this for the
subscriptions till next time